so at what point did you say
i got to get out of this i don't want to
do this anymore how long did that take
because i know you said that your family
thought you were dead for two years but
two years later they found that you're
not dead
when did you say i want out of this life
i tried to kill myself
how what happened what caused you to get
to that point
uh one time i was sitting in the top
building of iraqi olympic committee
uh today he raped a girl
and the father he was very now on
and back that as famous person you know
he coming to complain
and say to him you know you raped my
doctor
and this and that
or they were sitting behind his desk
office and
he started shouting them well what do
you want and your doctor she's a
and you know he starts screaming
and the other man he can't hear
somebody call his doctor who
he did something i i as i remember it's
petting him or something bad word he say
was sitting on this left with a table
front of me fruit and
he threw his gun to me like that and he
said to me shoot him
i took the gun and i put it in this
chair
they say shoot him i say no i'm not
doing that
you want to shoot him you do it it's not
me no i order you to shoot you i said
okay
took the knife and i start cutting i
myself
if you can see here
and here both sides
just the blood was all over
you crazy this would hospital they bring
me to hospital
uh yeah stitches and like that she come
on you're crazy you are this
or that anyway
to make it a little bit shorter until i
met the president
you know i said to him i don't want to
complete work with this guy
[Music]
he gave me a mercedes 300 seo
was zero mileage in it
and before
that i've been tortured
and thrown out of my family house they
didn't recognize me
because the guy what he said now in
jordan
he shaved my eyebrows my head
mustard you know this is a middle east
humiliation
my back you can't see only
lines is open blood
anyway i was really
sore you know they threw me like a
piece of potato like a bag of potatoes
outside the home
and my mother
my sister didn't recognize who i am only
through my voice
you know bald hair ball is nothing it's
like
boiled eggs they took me in
and you are dead
we did a funeral for you you know how
this happened i
i told them the story and uh
my dad he have a friend he have a
private hospital
in a good area
[Music]
he bring me to this hospital was a
poison in my blood
become you know muslim change all my
blood you know
from the torture and where they put me
and you know like
you know the manhole with a lot of
toilet stuff and death cards that
you know every rats everything with all
these torture and
my skin is open and infected
they threw me in uh inside this place
and you know i get
really infected in my body completely
my dad he bring me to this hospital
i stay over 40 days there
i was really really sane with myself
that's it
iraq is over for me it's completely over
but uh what they teach me in
intelligence service i should use it now
against them so don't be
stupid and do it quick think about it
and learn what they teach you how
and i was inside and i know how system
work
till one day after i really
uh get out of the hospital a little bit
my eyebrows my hair started growing
he sent somebody and call me a day
he have a party and harvest
monsoor hotel
he all these group got to be on
[Music]
matsukaman uh
before that i had a car
i am a fan of cars i really
up till now this age i buy anything
unusual about it
was a cadillac uh
if you see old videos of president ahmed
hassan bakker
long limousine black one i bought it
because of the history of it i bought it
and i want to sell it after one after
time one of his pimps
he want to buy it i said no i'm not
selling it
with the price you want to buy it
i say okay wait what's going to happen
make it shorter he went through all day
and told him lottie
told me i'm not selling cars for all day
pimps
and here when he saw me an el nino
monsoor
hotel take this to me
shouting this i took my girl
what she was with me which is
one to the left want to go down before
the door closed he starts shutting the
foot and shooting then i get
sworn in my shoulder
go down i took my car i never stopped
till mosul
god i didn't underst i from the hotel
till mosul but i was being chased
by his gun you know but
i'm a good driver good morning no stop
and every checkpoint i go like
half kilometer before i put the sensor
out of the lights
inside they opened no check no nothing
anyway i went to mosul from mosul they
smuggled me to
kurdistan
and another part of life start here
another chapter done so that was it you
were out you left
everything that's the laugh
november 1991
november 1991 so
the the assassination attempts then a
start you had three in vienna
i believe you had one in london and one
in norway right or am i missing one
correct
correct so they're still chasing you no
matter where you were going
yeah and when we say they is they
uday or is is it uday
kosei and uh saddam
not saddam i can say to you hundred
percent and i'll tell you the reason now
and definitely not jose because i was in
contact with jose
it was all day got it so you know it
wasn't jose
you know it wasn't saddam but you know
what's with these people that are coming
after you
yeah got it